امن. امريكا تؤكد عدم وجود اي
خطورة من تجربة موسكو لصاروخ
التصدي لسبع روسية في مناطق دون
سكوال لوجانسك. تحذير شديد
السيطرة على مصنع ازوفستال خلال
اربع وعشرين ساعة. كييف تعلن
باللين لم تفزع عن كل الاسلحة
التي ارسلتها لاوكرانيا. رويترز
المتحصنين في مصنع ازوفستال حال
قرروا الاستسلام. كما امر الرئيس
الاوروبي سيفعل كل ما في وسعه
لمساعدة اوكرانيا على الانتصار
ضمنها اكثر من سبعمائة من طائرات
سوتش بليد المسيرة. الامين العام
بوريس جونسون ان محادثات السلام
لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا محكوم
الفلسطينية. الاحداث والتطورات.
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
اسرائيلية تطلق النار على نقاط
رصد للفصائل الفلسطينية في قطاع
جيدا قبل اقدامه على شن غارات
قطاع غزة. بينما هناك اليات
اطلقت المقاومة وبشكل علني لاول
مرة صواريخ مضادة تلاحق الطائرات
امتلاك المقاومة لهذه الصواريخ
بعد تعرض طائراتها لهذه المضادات
ارض جو مضادة للطائرات وهو ما
تخشاه اسرائيل على طائراتها التي
منه المدنيون في اوكرانيا. سهام
قاتلة وخطيرة بطول سنتي مترين
سلمان بمستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي للبيت الابيض جيك
المتحدة ان تصرف النظر عن طلبها
لتعزيز انتاج النفط علاقة بين
بسبب الازمة الاوكرانية. السهام
الخطيرة. سلاح روسي خطير اشتكى
اولئك الذين يحاولون تهديد بلدنا
بخطاب متفلت وعدواني الى التفكير
المرحلة الثانية من العملية
العسكرية الروسية في اوكرانيا.
مقاتلو ماري بول يطلقون نداء
استغاثة للخروج من المدينة بشكل
مرتين. بينما يرد البنتاجون ان
التجربة الصاروخية الروسية
يزيد وزنه عن مائتي طن يصل مداه
لثمانية عشر الف كيلو متر ليخرج
من واشنطن. مسؤول اوكراني.
القوات الاوكرانية صامدة في
بايدن ادهشتني قوة الاوكرانيين
في مواجهة الروس قديروف يتوقع
البريطانية فان طائرة استطلاع
امريكية كانت تتعقب الطراد
الروسي قواته بالغاء اقتحام
المصنع والاكتفاء بمحاصرته.
بصاروخ يوم القيامة. الصاروخ
البالستي الثقيل العابر للقارات
يكون هذا التدخل سببا في اشعال
الحرب بين امريكا وروسيا? ما
لطالما حذرت منه اسرائيل
واردوغان يطالب برفع الظلم عن
امريكا تتسبب في اغراق اقوى
السفن الروسية وبوتين يرد باجراء
تجربة نووية للشيطان الاكبر. فهل
يدخل هذا الشيطان خط المعركة
العقوبات. انفصاليو دونيتسك
قواتنا تسيطر على اربع بلدات
سارمات وبوتين يهدد كالعادة
بينما يجري تصعيد خطير المقاومة
واضحة وننتظر الاجابة الكرة الان
في ملعب كييف. لكن ينفي اطلاعه
ماريو بول وترفض الاستسلام.
الاستخبارات البريطانية. روسيا
تتقدم الان نحو مدينة
كراماتورسك. بايدن مع حلفاء
اللهجة من روسيا الى فنلندا
والسويد من الانضمام الى حلف
في الحرب. الكرملين سلمنا
اوكرانيا مسودة وثيقة بصيغة
في مصنع ازوفستال مهلة جديدة
للاستسلام. وكالة الفرنسية.
الامن الكامل لسكان قال ان بلاده
مستعدة لمبادلة المقاتلين
لكسر الحصار عن المدينة. اعلنت
القيادة العسكرية لجنوب اوكرانيا
بوتين وزلنسكي. انفصاليو دونيتسك
استسلام خمسة وثلاثين عسكريا
ان قواتها قصفت الجيش الروسي
شمال خرسون. الولايات المتحدة
للامم المتحدة طلب ترتيب زيارتين
له الى موسكو وكييب للاجتماع مع
الناتو. وتقول موسكو ان الناتو
يجتذب الدولتين الى صفوفه بايعاز
الاسرائيلية وتبنت حركة القسام
ذلك الهجوم في تطور جديد يؤكد ان
اردوجان بقوله دعونا المجتمع
الدولي وكافة المنظمات الدولية
عليها بالفشل لان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين لا يمكن الوثوق
المدافعين عن ماريبول باسرى روس
كما طالب بدعم عسكري دولي عاجل
المقاومة باتت تمتلك المضادات
التي تجبر الاحتلال على التفكير
به بحسب وصفه. فلاديمير بوتين
عملياتنا العسكرية ستستمر حتى
ونصف. هذه السهام ممنوعة خلال
الحروب لانها عشوائية وتضر
سوليفان بعد ان اثار الاخير قضية
مقتل الصحفي السعودي جمال
على الحدود. استطاعت المقاومة
الفلسطينية الحصول على صواريخ
اكثر من مرة. وبعد ان نفذت
اسرائيل عدة غارات على قطاع غزة
دوليين فرض المزيد من العقوبات
على روسيا. لافروف يؤكد انطلاق
تحلق بشكل دائم فوق سماء غزة.
وكانت تل ابيب قد حذرت سابقا من
جديدة جنوب غرب المدينة ليرتفع
عدد البلدات التي سيطرنا عليها
الى مائة وسبعة وستين. بوتين
سنضمن ممرا امنا للجنود
المضادة للطائرات ويمكنه تدمير
مناطق شاسعة. صاروخ سارمات الذي
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعد اجراءات
جديدة لمنع روسيا من تجنب
على وثيقة السلام المقدمة من
روسيا. وزيرة الخارجية الالمانية
الجيش الاوكراني بصاروخ نبتون
المضاد للسفن. ووفقا لصحيفة
بالمدنيين بشكل كبير وهي ما
استخدمه الروسي بعد خروجه من
الولايات المتحدة والسعودية وصلت
الى ادنى مستوياتها منذ عقود
روتينية ولا تشكل تهديدا على
امريكا وحلفائها. وقد اخطرت
المحاصرة. بعد لقائه قال رئيس
المجلس الاوروبي ان الاتحاد
موثوق امن روسيا من التهديدات
الخارجية. كما بوتين تحذيره
اوكرانيا في مصنع ازوفستال
بماريوبول وموسكو تمنح المقاتلين
للغرب قائلا صاروخ سارمات الروسي
لا مثيل له في العالم. وسيدفع
موسكفا في الساعات التي سبقت
تعرضه للهجوم من قبل الجيش
اوكرانيا تعرض على روسيا اجراء
مفاوضات في مدينة ماريوبول
تتعهد بمساعدة الاوكرانيين
للحصول على واسلحة وذخائر من
الفلسطينية في القطاع. ليأتي
تصريح قوي من الرئيس التركي
للتحرك في وجه الظلم الذي يتعرض
له الفلسطينيون وسنستمر ذلك.
فكيف ستنتهي هذه التصعيدات بين
المحتل الاسرائيلي والمقاومة
بوتشا بحسب المدنيين الاوكران.
رد مفاجئ. رغم التشديدات الامنية
خاشقجي. وابلغ ابن سلمان ضيفه
الامريكي ان على الولايات
الجيل الخامس قادر على التفوق
على جميع الانظمة الحديثة
صاروخية لصاروخها صارمات او
الشيطان الاكبر والملقب ايضا
فلسطين. تدخل امر طائرة امريكية
مخصصة لرصد السفن الحربية كانت
يعني حربا عالمية ثالثة بدون شك?
صار مات. روسيا تجري تجربة
بكارثة انسانية في اوكرانيا
هجمات روسية ورد اوكراني في حين
اوكرانيا فعلا في الهجوم من خلال
تقديم بيانات استخباراتية. فهل
الاوكراني. ومع ذلك رفضت البحرية
الامريكية تأكيد ما اذا قد ساعدت
موسكو واشنطن بهذه التجربة. لقاء
متوتر. كشفت صحيفة وول ستريت
بعد تجربة بوتين ويقول صاروخ
سارمات سلاح فريد سيضمن بشكل
جورنال الامريكية عن لقاء عاصف
جمع ولي العهد السعودي محمد بن
سوليفان بالسعودية انتهى اللقاء
بان صرخ ابن سلمان في وجه
قريبة من مكان الطراد الروسي
موسكو قبل ان يستهدف من قبل
يطرح الكرملين وثيقة مشروطة
لانهاء الحرب فهل تستجيب
اوكرانيا للطلبات الروسية?
المقاومة الفلسطينية ترد بسلاح
والغرب لتحرير اراضيهم روسيا
تستخدم سلاحا خطيرا قد يتسبب
غزة. كما قصفت مقاتلات حربية
اسرائيلية ايضا موقعا للمقاومة
بداية مرحلة ثانية من العمليات
وسط حصار على ما تبقى من مدينة
الحالية السعودية ترفض طلب
اميركا في العلن وموسكو تعلن
ماريبول. في المقابل ينتظر
الاوكرانيون دعما سخيا من امريكا
الفلسطينية وقوات الاحتلال. فهل
تندلع معارك ضارية بين الطرفين?